Das EEG. Diese Untersuchung dient der Beurteilung der Gehirnfunktion.
Die Untersuchung ist schmerzfrei, hat keine Nebenwirkung, dauert nur ein paar Minuten.
Mit der Untersuchung messen wir die elektrischen Ströme im Gehirn.
Damit können wir Veränderung der Hirnaktivität sehen.
Zum Beispiel auch im Rahmen einer Epilepsie.
Die elektrische Aktivität des Gehirns wird in Kurven aufgezeichnet.
Wir können sehen, ob ein Krampfleiden oder auch eine Epilepsie besteht.
Es kann auch sein, dass die Gehirnfunktion aktuell ganz normal ist.
Trotzdem eine Epilepsie besteht.
Ganz sicher lässt sich das dann vielleicht nicht ausschließen.
Wenn Sie direkt mit den Patienten sprechen, sagen Sie,
wir kleben für ein paar Minuten ein paar Metallplättchen,
die sogenannten Elektroden auf die Kopfhaut.
Und die Untersuchung kann ambulant durchgeführt werden.
Das heißt, Sie müssen dafür nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Wenn Sie mit Eltern eines Kindes, also eines jüngeren Patienten reden,
sagen Sie zum Beispiel, wir kleben für ein paar Minuten
ein paar Metallplättchen, sogenannte Elektroden,
die Kopfhaut Ihres Kindes oder Ihre Tochter Ihres Sohnes.
Die Untersuchung kann ambulant durchgeführt werden.
Das heißt, Ihre Tochter oder Ihr Sohn kann direkt danach wieder nach Hause.